[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is normally my job
to deconstruct world-class performers of
all different types
from all different disciplines and i am
thrilled to have
as my guest today a polymath i would
certainly consider him a polymath
jordan b peterson he has taught
mythology to lawyers doctors and
business people consulted for the u.n
secretary general
helped his clinical clients manage
depression obsessive compulsive disorder
anxiety and schizophrenia
served as an advisor to senior partners
of major canadian law firms
and lectured extensively in north
america and europe with his students and
colleagues at harvard and the university
of toronto
dr peterson has published more than 100
scientific papers
transforming the modern understanding of
personality
as his book maps of meaning subtitled
the architectural belief revolutionized
the psychology of religion
his book 12 rules for life an antidote
to chaos was published in 2018 and has
sold more than four million copies
internationally
his newest book is beyond order 12
more rules for life you can find him
online at jordanbpeterson.com on twitter
jordanb peterson instagram jordan.b
dot peterson facebook you guessed it dr
jordan b pedersen
youtube jordanpedersonvideos and you can
find his personality assessment
at understandingmyself.com and the self
authoring program at selfauthoring.com
jordan
welcome to the show thank you god it's
hard to hear my name
so many times without becoming somewhat
nauseated
it's yeah that's how i feel when i
listen to my
my own playback in this podcast and
i'm thrilled to finally have you on the
podcast
we are going to run out of time before
we run out of material
and yeah
that would be and i want to start
in maybe an odd place
and that is asking if you could
describe to my audience who sandy notley
was
oh well i grew up in a small town in
northern alberta
i heard you and my producer talking
about cold in minnesota and i was sort
of smirking in the background i thought
you guys don't know what cold is uh when
i went to college there
about 60 miles away we had 30 days in a
row one winter where it didn't get above
minus 40.
so anyhow i grew up in this small town
and
in the province of alberta so that's the
canadian equivalent of a state
and we had a provincial government the
equivalent of a state government and it
was all conservatives
progressive conservative party every
seat in in the house was progressive
conservative except
one new democratic party member
socialist
uh grant notley who was the leader of
the ndp and
he wasn't elected so much because he was
a socialist i don't think because most
of the people in my small town were
conservative but because he was a really
good man
anyways he was the only opposition in
the entire province for
like decade a decade or more um
his wife sandy naughtly was a new
englander
and uh somewhat
of an anomaly in our small town and she
she was quite outspoken
uh new england intellectual um
and she was our librarian in our junior
high school
and all the delinquents and me as well
and maybe i was in that category hung
out in the library weirdly enough
because she treated us like adults
and i started to work for the ndp when i
was 14.
i ran for vice president of the party
when i was 14. that was my first sort of
public exposure but
she was a good guide for me she
introduced me to a lot of
books i was an omnivorous reader but
mostly i read science fiction i didn't
know what the hell to read
i used to spend all you know i'd hide my
the books i was reading behind a
textbook in class and read away during
school
but i was reading mostly science fiction
and she
started to hand me
books that she thought would be good for
me um she introduced me to anne rand
um interestingly enough despite the fact
that she was a socialist
uh not and rand obviously but sandy
notley
she said she thought i would be smart
enough to see through rand um
uh huxley orwell solzhenitsyn
uh a lot of serious material and i
developed a real friendship with her and
her husband and i worked
with ndp for four years so
she was a pronounced influence on me
and uh that's sandy naughtley oh and her
daughter
rachel notley who was a friend of mine a
girlfriend of one of my close friends
at one point became premier of alberta
many years later she was defeated in the
last election which was only about
three years ago but she followed in her
father's footsteps and
and became premier of the province so
that's that story
on your website you have an extensive
list of recommended books i've looked at
it
looked at it multiple years it's close
to 100 i would say
and they're they're put into different
categories different genres
are there any books on that list
or can you think of books that were
introduced relatively early in your life
some of the early exposures that have
stood the test of time for you
no huxley and orwell i would say
solzhenitsyn as well i read one day in
the life of van dijkovich when i was
13 or 14 that was one of the books
natalie recommended
and so they they certainly had an impact
on me uh
what was that impact if uh if you if you
don't mind me
following up well you know i started to
think in broader terms as a consequence
of being introduced to books like that
and started to think more seriously from
a political persp
from a political perspective and
psychological perspective i i suppose
it was my first introduction into
serious thought
and so and it was extremely exciting i
mean i i
i read a lot of english literature
from until i was about 25 and then i
started reading nonfiction more once i
started my graduate studies
but it opens up a world of ideas and
that was really exciting to me
incredibly exciting to me so and the
reason i'm asking so much about books is
is i'm i i am really fascinated
uh by you and i'm fascinated by everyone
i have on the show but the
formation of your
well that sort of decreases my my
pleasure at being the object of current
fascination well
right now you are the most fascinating
person in the world to me
and i uh
i find that books are a
sort of a wellspring of
value for listeners because it's
something they can model very well
something that they can reach out for uh
so so let's
yeah well people can get a whole
education if they read those hundred
books that i have on my website
i mean you're not going to get an
education in every every discipline but
there's a whole education there under
recommended books
that's been fun because lots of people
have that that's been an unbelievably
popular list
it sells hundreds of books a month i
believe it
and people email me constantly and say
well you know you introduced me to
dostoyevsky thanks a lot
i'm i've been they're so enthralled if
you're psychologically minded
and you like dark the darkness to some
degree you know if you like
gothic imagery and and film noir and
that sort of thing
dostoevsky is an unbelievable treat and
he's
so incredibly deep psychologically
enthralling crime and punishment is an
absolutely engrossing novel
as well as being a stunning work of
philosophy
another name that shows up not once but
several times in that list
is nietzsche if i'm pronouncing that
remotely correctly i've always wondered
i never know i pronounce it like
northern albertan nietzsche
i know that's wrong it's nietzsche i
believe but i never get it right
i've i've read you highlight in a sense
or at least mention that nietzsche
pointed out that most morality is
cowardice so for making the leap
from sort of this list of books to
specific ideas
could you please elaborate on that
well if you don't have the courage if
you don't have the courage to commit a
crime it doesn't mean you're moral for
not doing it
it just means you're afraid you can see
this i suppose to some degree in
in mob violence people will riot because
they don't think they'll get caught
and so they're not law abiding under
normal circumstances because they're
moral they're law abiding because
they're afraid of punishment
and so nietzsche was very
uh careful to distinguish mere
obedience from morality and
he thought of obedience not always as a
form of cowardice because it can also be
a source of discipline
but
not committing a crime because you're
too afraid to
i mean it's probably better than
committing a crime but it doesn't speak
to the essence of morality
you know and i've talked a fair bit
about this is that
there there's there's a certain utility
in being able to do virtually anything
and then to control yourself
and that's something i learned in part
from nietzsche i suppose
you know the best people i've ever met
are dangerous people
but they keep themselves in check i have
a close friend who's been real
rock to me over the last couple of years
he was also
born in northern alberta he came from a
pretty poverty stricken background
tough guy worked in lead smelters and
oil rigs and
he went to university which is where i
met him and then he was a social worker
for a long time and
he's tough as nails you know he's worked
with delinquents all over canada and
he's a good disciplinarian but he's
he's also a very compassionate person
and
he's a he's a moral person as far as i'm
concerned because there's a real danger
to him
but he keeps it under control and
it's he's not a coward he's not afraid
he's not weak
how do you how do you cultivate or
suggest people cultivate you can
you can tackle either both the ability
to keep yourself in check or under
control
and to be courageous and it's just to
provide
a little context for the question when i
s when i see you in
the the many interviews that you've done
there are instances where people are
very
adversarial and aggressive and
one thing that has struck me is your
ability to
maintain composure while still
standing up for not rolling over with
respect to your
your arguments or your positions how do
you cultivate that or how have you
cultivated that
well i have an advantage i suppose in
that i'm a clinical psychologist and
i've spent twenty thousand dollars
although i'm not practicing anymore
i've spent twenty thousand dollars
listening to people and maintaining my
composure
sometimes under very stressful
circumstances um
and so i've had a lot of practice doing
that
um and then i did do some tv work
at a local station here for a couple of
years and
i had a good producer and he helped me
realize that anger plays very badly
in a public forum like video and
particularly
now i didn't have a tendency then i
supposed to fly off the handle either
but it's not useful
to lose your temper it's not useful i
mean i'm boiling
inside i'm a very emotional person way
too much
so it's not like it's not stressful it's
unbelievably stressful
but i can detach myself from that to
some degree
and i'm really curious i suppose that's
another part of it i like to watch
and when people really go after me this
is where the clinical
practice is handy
i can snap into a different mode which
is okay i don't know what you're up to
so i'm just going to watch you and then
i'm going to figure out what you're up
to
because i can usually figure out what
people are up to
if i want to i i don't do that all the
time because
i actually don't want to know sometimes
what they're up to
i mean look people lots of people have
treated me extraordinarily well don't
get me wrong
but um and normally you know when when
you talk to someone
you accept their persona you don't look
behind but if people mistreat me
in some way or or become adversarial
then i'm able to look behind the scene
and think and see what they're up to
if i can remember to do that do you look
behind
the the mask or see what is behind
by deducing where they're trying to
leave
where they're trying to lead you with
the breadcrumbs i mean i see i've seen
you
do that very effectively yeah that's
part of it
what other forms does that take or might
that take
it's really hard to describe i i guess i
i i think it's useful to draw a
distinction between thinking and paying
attention
if you if you're thinking you're kind of
walking down a
programmatic trail if you're paying
attention
you just open your eyes and let your
mind
go where it will and ideas will occur to
you
they'll pop up in your field of
consciousness and
for me that's often informative i'll get
insight
that way i suppose i'm paying more
attention to non-verbal communication
and to
you know facial expression and posture
and
and and tone of voice and i can pick up
patterns
i suppose you mentioned earlier
that at times you're you're boiling
inside uh i
certainly have experienced that
personally now anger
how would you distinguish and and i sort
of intuitively
know these are different but i would
struggle to maybe
on the spot separate the two anger and
resentment because
uh one of your quotes that i
have here in front of me with my notes
is consult your resentment
it is revelatory and i'd love to unpack
i'd love to unpack that uh but if you
could
walk us through yeah well in my new book
i have a chapter
which is rule 11 do not allow yourself
to become resentful
deceitful or arrogant it's kind of the
evil triad as far as i've been able to
determine
resentment in particular it's bad it's a
it's a bad emotion it's useful
you can learn a lot by noticing that it
occurs resentment tells you one of two
things
one is that you're that someone's
treading on your territory and
something needs to be done about it or
that you need to grow the hell up and
stop complaining and it's hard it isn't
necessarily obvious
when you feel resentful which of those
it is
but you need to figure it out you know
because you can
you can harbor resentment for for
unlived life
for for a very very long period of time
and all it does is corrupt you it
hurts you hurts you physically because
it's a stressful emotion
anger is a stressful emotion um because
your body
hyper prepares for action if you're
angry because
you might get into conflict so and
that's a high
that's a dangerous situation and so you
burn off a lot of
psychophysiological resources in anger
if you're resentful there's probably
something you need to say
there's certainly something you need to
figure out
and so you can you can use it as a guide
to further development
it's very much useful to to aim at a
resentment free existence
and that means i suppose that you're
taking up enough space
you know you're not there's always a
struggle between your domain and
the domain of other people everyone
competes for everyone else's attention
everyone competes for everyone else's
time you compete for your own time
and if you're resentful it's highly
probable that well as i said either
you're not standing up for yourself
sufficiently or someone is legitimately
on your case in which case you well you
need to do something about that
or you know live with the consequences
which is very unpleasant it's not
optimal
sometimes i suppose it's unavoidable but
you know generally there's something
that can be done about it
maybe you need a new job it's easy for
people to think that they're better than
they are
and it's not surprising that everybody
wants to think that
i probably want to think that about me
so then you'll get angry about something
you know maybe your partner puts you
down
in public doesn't show you the respect
maybe you're married saying husband and
wife owe each other
a certain amount of categorical respect
sort of independent of the individual
personalities
you know what if you have decided that
you're going to devote your life to
someone and vice versa
they're now in a category that requires
a certain amount of respect
and to maintain the relationship over
time that's good for your partner and
it's also
good for you maybe you've taken a shot
in public
and you're really angry about it and but
you don't notice it because you want to
think that you're better than you are
that sort of thing doesn't upset you and
so you don't say anything about it you
don't do anything about it and
then you don't fix it and that's a
mistake it's much better you could say
to your partner look you know we're out
for dinner
tonight and you said something snarky
which i didn't think was appropriate now
i might be a hypersensitive um i might
be hypersensitive and touchy and
immature and maybe you hit me in a weak
spot
or maybe you're playing some power game
why don't we figure that out
now that's messy people don't like
conversations like that
and i think that's one of the things
that's peculiar about me
for one i don't know why exactly but i
don't
like that i i won't let those things go
so the peculiarity is that you'll you'll
open those conversations you don't have
an aversion to it
well i have a horrible adversion to it
and i don't like
conflict but i've learned and i this is
partly i suppose clinical training but
it's not just that
some things if you don't address them
they just get worse
and i've i've been able to see where
things are going to go it's kind of like
what i
mentioned to you earlier that if i watch
someone
i can generally figure out what they're
up to
i also can see where things are going
and
so you know if if if i walk into
someone's house and
there are things out of order in a
particular way
if i pay attention to that that's in
that's often indicative of something not
right in the relationship
you know maybe the kitchen's a mess it's
like
there's no there's food that isn't fresh
in the fridge for example or
or there's packages up in shelves that
haven't been opened for like two years
or since the wedding let's say um
that's too much chaos in the kitchen
something's wrong well what's wrong well
there's something wrong in the domestic
relationship
there the bargaining about who does what
in the kitchen hasn't been
fought through and so
you have to have those fights to put
things in order and
if you don't then you end up with a
worse fight in the future
and so the reason that i call things out
as far as i can tell the positive reason
who knows what the negative reasons are
is because i don't
want more conflict i'd rather have
genuine peace which is very very very
hard to obtain
people generally obtain peace by
sweeping things under the carpet
i have another chapter in this new book
called don't hide things in the fog
and it that's what it concentrates on is
pay attention to your negative emotions
resentment particularly it's like
it's so it's so uh
informative you find out where you're
immature
well do you want to probably not who
wants to find out that
or you'll find out who's oppressing you
and maybe then you can learn to stand up
for yourself
well let's let's dig into the new book i
want to do it in a particular way
which is starting with a quote of yours
that
a close friend of mine has committed to
memory now
please fact check me on this perhaps
it's abraham lincoln or oscar wilde or
one of the other
ubiquitous attributions on the internet
but but here we go
and i'm fond of this as well quote it
seems to me that the purpose of life is
to find a mode of being that is so
meaningful that the fact that life is
suffering is no longer
relevant uh now i have a i have a
follow-up just a
segue from that but is that an accurate
quote
well i don't know if it's an accurate
quote but it sounds like something i
probably said
accurate sentiment a a a
attributed accurately attributed all
right it seems to me that it's true
i mean it isn't necessarily the case
that you can do it
all right yeah it's right it's hard to
do i mean
and that of course it's hard i suppose
in proportion to the suffering that
you're undergoing
and it isn't necessarily the case that
you can always manage it but
but but sometimes you can manage it and
and it's good if you can
so i want to uh use
your book as a
i mean prop isn't the right word a
vehicle for exploring this
uh one of the books that you often
reference
is man search for meaning by viktor
frankl
sorry i'm gonna i'm gonna stop just for
a sec because i thought about some other
things
so this is partly why
i have a certain
conservative bent i suppose see
people need to search for meaning
because they get corrupted by suffering
if their life isn't meaningful
that's how it looks to me because you
can't torture an animal
forever without it lashing out
and so if your life is nothing if
there's nothing in it that speaks to you
there's still going to be suffering you
can't talk yourself
out of that and so then i see people
tearing
tearing down traditional structures
let's say
or they're casual about them another
rule in this new book is uh
do not casually denigrate social
institutions or creative achievement
well why social institutions well i've
counseled lots of people who were lost
and so if you came to see me and i was
your therapist
i'm very practical i'd say to you okay
well let's look at your life for a
minute
um do you have an intimate relationship
what about your family and that could be
you know married with kids or it could
be the family of your birth
your siblings and your parents and so on
how's that functioning do you have
anyone there
do you have a job or maybe a career even
if you're fortunate at least a job that
keeps body and soul together and maybe
where there's some chance of advancement
and hope
do you know how to use your time outside
of work productively
do you take care of your mental and
physical health do you manage
the temptations drug and alcohol use and
that sort of thing do you manage those
temptations effectively
um are you educated as
are you as educated as you are
intelligent you know have you
and those are standard
those are standard patterns of activity
in the world do you have kids do you
have a wife do you or a husband do you
have a job
i mean it's mundane in some sense but
and you can look beyond all those
standard answers for meaning
but if you're overwhelmed by life
anxious and
and suffering that's a good place to
start put that together
why well the answer to that is because
that's what people do
that's what people do that's the best
we've been able to manage
and so and if you don't have that
because you're a human being like other
human beings
you're going to suffer for it
and so attacks on that assaults on that
aren't that helpful
unless you have a better like i have
this friend he's an atheist
and he's wavering about this he was born
a communist he was raised in poland
and he had objected at one point to
the christmas traditions of his family
who were also atheistic and uh
you know he objected on the grounds of
logical coherence
why are we doing this well
don't do it well then what happens well
then you have another weekday
you lose christmas well
great it's like now you're logically
coherent wonderful
but you've lost christmas you don't want
to throw these things away
you know when i see this sometimes with
young people when they're talking about
getting married
we don't need to get married we don't
need a piece of paper it's like
really that's your that's the depth of
thought you've put into this
it's like you're not going to mark this
permanence
with conscious awareness and social
celebration and the sanction of your
community and
a beautiful ceremony that's just nothing
you let that go well what do you
what are you going to replace it with
nothing oh
you know you can say it's it's i don't
want to be married in a church
i don't believe in god fair enough but
good luck filling in the hole
so what is the template for constructive
criticism of a social institution in
other words if there is a wrong way to
do it
where you're creating a void and not
offering a better solution
what is the what is the better
approach or what might be you know i got
well known i suppose in part because of
my injunction to people
that they clean up their room my closet
by the way is a mess i haven't been able
to clean it up for like three years
so um there's this english common law
principle with regards to the
distribution of power
i think it's english common law
that there are certain responsibilities
of the family and
the community in the town and the state
and the and the
federal government and the international
organizations and
but you want to have the most proximal
level possible take responsibility for a
given
enterprise and i think that's a good
philosophy personally
you want to make changes start with
what's under your control
start with changing those things that
will hurt you if the changes go wrong
there's a good one you know and it's
better i think to put your life together
than to go worry about parading around
and being a social activist i think
most of that's fraudulent and i think
it's appalling that
students learn or people learn to do
that mostly at universities i think it's
it's it's it's appalling
fix up your own life and that doesn't
mean you shouldn't be involved in the
community but
i believe that you you have to earn that
right
not only not because there's something
more wrong with you than wrong with
anyone else
it's just that you don't want to
if you if you operate at a level that's
beyond your competence all you're going
to do is make catastrophic mistakes
practice locally till you're competent
and then
if you dare well move out a little bit
you know as you mature
and you gain some when i when i used to
work for the ndp
the socialists back when i was 14 or 15.
one of the things i came to realize i
think i realized this when i was 16 and
went to university
it's like i woke up one day and i
thought i had this ideology in my mind
you know about how the world should be
structured and i woke up one day and i
thought
what the hell do you know
you don't have a family you don't have
any experience you don't have a job
like you're a pup i mean i was smart
enough i
verbally could hold my own and my head
was full of ideas i could defend them
but you know at the same time that i was
a socialist
kid i was i sat on the board of
governors for the local college
and almost all the people on that board
were local businessmen
most of them immigrants because northern
alberta was an immigrant
like it was only 50 years old everybody
had moved there it was a new place it
was the end of the frontier literally we
were at the end of the railway the
northernmost tip of the
north american prairie and there was all
these conservatives
sitting on this board and me and
what i found was i actually respected
these people
like i didn't i wasn't my ideology my
explicit ideology was antithetical to
theirs but when i
interacted with them one-on-one i
thought hmm
these people have made something of
themselves and
uh when i talked to the activists
i never got that impression i thought
you guys are resentful as hell
and you don't know anything you've never
done anything but you're noisy and
self-righteous and so that put a lot of
cognitive dissonance that filled me with
cognitive dissonance
so i was gonna go to victor frankel
but i'd like to pull a hard left oh it's
a dangerous thing
it is a dangerous thing especially
depending on the country you're in
especially
uh and we'll come back to victor frankel
because i would like to ask about it
about him but but first i'd like to go
to
uh aldous huxley and possibly hunter s
thompson
oh yeah i was interested to see
fear and loathing in las vegas by hunter
s thompson
on your on your list of suggested books
and uh
island or the island i don't know if
there's a
the in the title by aldous huxley and
going into or down the rabbit hole
with your videos and interviews i
noticed that you seem to have quite a
familiarity with
the research done by rick strassman
with intravenous nndmt and also
the psilocybin research at johns hopkins
with roland griffiths matt johnson and
and their entire team uh but in the
clips that i've seen
there isn't really a lot of context
there's snippets that i've found
what has been the context for
introducing those to your classes or in
your lectures
well i did my phd in
alcoholism so psychopharmacology i mean
i've got a phd in clinical psychology
but my research was
for years eight years nine years
was all drug and alcohol abuse i
concentrated on alcohol but that was
okay because
alcohol is like water it it crosses the
blood-brain barrier
like water it bathes every cell it has
polysystemic effects and so if you study
alcohol
from the psychological and and
pharmacological perspective
you have to learn the function of the
systems that all drugs affect
you know all drugs of abuse affect
fundamental motivational or emotional
systems that's why we take them
although with the hallucinogens it's
more complex you know like
benzodiazepines and barbiturates and
alcohol they're
they're anxiolytics they reduce anxiety
alcohol also has a dopaminergic effect
for some people kind of like cocaine
or amphetamines um there's the
analgesics like heroin or cocaine
cocaine is also analgesic so well the
psychomotor stimulants are analgesic as
well
but the big categories are pain
relieving anxiety relieving and
and psychomotor stimulant and and most
drugs of abuse fall into those
categories and then there's the
hallucinogens which are their whole
whole other
universe and so i'm well versed in in
the psychology of and the physiology of
drug and alcohol
use and so that's the context that's
part of it anyways i'm also interested
in
religious experiences and for one reason
or another
and it's a bottomless mystery um
there are agents that reliably produce
religious experiences
and no one knows what in the world to do
about that
that's for sure
[Laughter]
there are there's a there's a study
ongoing
at hopkins also that that's looking at
the effects
of uh serotonin 2a agonists
like psilocybin's effects on
world view of religious leaders of
different
faiths which which uh oh is that right
and how are they doing that
well they do they're doing it with as i
understand it administration
uh probably 30 milligrams of synthetic
psilocybin wow that should definitely be
illegal
should be illegal or illegal well it's
no wonder it was all made illegal i mean
it's pandora's box
in in what in what respect what would
your what would your concerns be
with that particular pandora's box well
look what happened when psychedelics
were introduced into the culture in the
1960s
you know it was it was revolutionary no
one knew what
no one knew how to regulate or control
it and i don't mean control by clamp
down i just meant
no one knew what to do with it i mean it
knocked timothy leary off to the side
sideways you know and i had timothy
leary's old position at harvard
okay he had the same position as me yeah
so that was kind of interesting
yeah i think i think the i mean the
social dynamics are very different
in the sense that yes there are a lot of
risks psychological
uh in rare cases physical
with psychedelic use but
um i'm very involved with the phase
three
trials both for psilocybin and mdma
assisted psychotherapy quite
separately is griffiths running now
griffiths is
involved so they would be one site for
the
phase three trials yeah well he's the
real scientist he's great he's a he's a
close
he's a close friend uh and uh he's i met
him at a conference on
awe he's an excellent excellent
scientist with a lot of
a lot of exposure to uh
psychoactives uh expert in caffeine
metabolism and all things caffeine among
other compounds
the i mean you've spoken in in the
videos i've seen at least of the changes
in openness yes they're pronounced
would that not be a positive thing if
that is a consequence of opening
pandora's box
depends on how neurotic you are
no i mean technically this is the
technical discussion
openness isn't much fun if you're high
in neuroticism all right
because you continually undermine
yourself like openness is creativity but
let's let's not be all
polyannish about this there wouldn't be
variation in creativity if it wasn't
dangerous
there's lots of people who are very low
in openness and there's a reason for
that
now it has advantages you know open
people
occupy a particular niche they're on the
edge
jordan would you mind defining openness
in this particular
context sure well people people who are
open
um there's creativity essentially
creativity and verbal fluency
together make up openness now it's also
associated with
verbal iq so it's the one there's five
personality traits
extroversion it's positive emotion
neuroticism
that's negative emotion agreeableness
that's compassion versus
predatory aggression something like that
conscientiousness
that's dutifulness orderliness um
and then openness which is um
intellect interest in ideas and
creativity
and you know you might think the more of
that the better but
no that isn't how nature works
you can undo yourself by being open
people who are open have a hard time
catalyzing their identity because
they're so
protein they shift shapes constantly
they're interested in everything it
makes it very hard for them to pursue
one thing and it my observation is that
if people are
high in negative emotion so they're
prone to anxiety for example
then being open can be a curse because
along when you expose yourself to
something that's unknown
you know the extroversion and openness
can drive you forward
as a function of of curiosity and
engagement but
the uncertainty is also the uncertainty
you pay a price for physiologically
because when you're when you face
something uncertain your body
like when you're angry your body has to
prepare for anything
and that's expensive and physiologically
demanding
and so and open people they flip things
upside down all the time
and that's dangerous like it isn't like
it's not
necessary don't get me wrong it's
necessary
this chapter i made allusion to i said
don't casually
criticize social institutions or
creative achievement i picked those
phrases very carefully we need social
institutions
but they become corrupt and so we need
creative revolution
but it can get out of hand and so
there's this constant
war between the strictures of tradition
and the transformation of creativity
and you can't say who's right you can
just
talk it out yeah but
you know what the psilocybin you take
one dose and have a mystical experience
and you're
you move from 50th percentile openness
to 85th percentile
with one dose it's a major neurological
rewiring
it's it's stunning it's stunning and you
know you could say well that
i'm sure there are things about that
that are good but jung said
beware of unearned wisdom
it's a good quote it is a good quote you
know jung
really puzzles me because it's never
clear to me how he knew the things he
knew and
that's one really good example of that
so on the on the openness just to
explore this a bit further you know it
it also seems
again i'm not a clinician but but
speaking just as a
as a as someone at least involved on
some
on some level with the the the science
and there's an open person
i try yeah oh no there's no doubt about
it given what you do you're
entrepreneurial
and you're interested in ideas like your
your cardinal personality trait
undoubtedly is openness and
you know if if you can manage it it's a
great trait
yeah so the on on one hand on the one
hand
you have uh disqualifying
criteria for becoming a subject in the
psilocybin studies schizophrenia being
one of them or a family history
of schizophrenia uh which
you know seems to overlap with some of
what you were saying earlier right there
are risk factors
uh if if you are sort of swimming closer
to the
the bank of the river that is chaos yeah
if you're schizophrenic if you're
schizophrenic you should stay away from
amphetamines
it's pretty obvious that the um whatever
the hallucinogens do
isn't the same as schizophrenia that's
people think that but you can induce
paranoid schizophrenia
in normal people by overdosing the
moment on amphetamines
yeah so not still it might not be a good
idea if
you have a family history to you know to
mess around
yeah it seems it seems to possibly
accelerate the onset not that they're
the same thing although these
drugs used to be referred to as
psychomimetics but that's since been
somewhat disproven in terms of
neurological correlates just looking at
mri fmri scans and so on now on the
other hand
you have acute anxiety in some cases
chronic but acute anxiety and say
terminal cancer patients
which hopkins has also uh is a
population hopkins has worked with
yeah and in those cases the shift
openness can be
life-changingly positive well i don't
know if it's
shift to openness exactly or if it's the
religious aspect of the experience
true yeah true absolutely if you have
ego dissolution that can do
something for fear of death oh yeah i
think i also think that's
that's phenomenal research it's
unbelievably interesting
um you know and it's certainly the case
that like i
firmly believe that the world is not the
way we perceive it it's
deeply it's deeply strange
and i do believe that the hallucinogens
reveal that
um and i you know i don't think that
attempts to drive them underground have
been particularly fruitful
one of the consequences of the war on
drugs is now we have like 500
psychoactive chemicals instead of 20 or
30 you know because chemists keep
chasing the laws and
so making it illegal isn't doesn't look
like a good solution
i wouldn't i wouldn't uh that doesn't
mean we have a good solution
yeah yeah 100 agreed i mean if you just
look also at
black market synthesis of something like
mdma you have deforestation in cambodia
or you have chemicals being dumped in
holland which is a real nexus for
production
if you legalize and regulate and tax
that as you would any other industry
then many of those problems
cease to be problems not to make it
sound easy
but i agree with you as i suppose what
i'm saying
i have to ask before we go to victor
frankel if if you're able to put words
to it
in what ways do you think reality is
deeply strange
can you elaborate on that in any way
there's a narrative aspect to it there's
a religious
aspect to it there's a meaningful aspect
to it
that we don't understand we can't
understand it scientifically or we
haven't been able to
the scientific viewpoint excludes that
to some degree
and i think the best evidence for that
probably does come from hallucinogenic
experience
now people have clearly people have
a biologically instantiated religious
instinct
now it's possible that that only speaks
of our peculiar biological nature
that it doesn't reflect broader reality
as such but
if you go deep enough into the psyche
what you it becomes increasingly
difficult to
separate what you discover from reality
now it's not people can clearly have
individual subjective religious
experiences
most scientific phenomena are objective
many people have to experience the
phenomena at the same time
you have these religious experiences
that can be induced by
hallucinogens let's say each person has
their own particular experience but
everyone has an experience that's
similar and we don't know what to do
about that
category of experience and then
you know we think in stories and we see
the world through a structure of value
i think that's i think that that
has been proven beyond a doubt by
neuroscientists and psychologists
and the fact that we see the world
through a prism of value
seems to indicate that there's something
about value that's real
and so that's partly why things are
deeply mysterious
i mean rick strassmann he terrified
himself right out of the dmt research as
far as i could tell because
all his subjects came back and said well
you know i
went somewhere else and saw aliens it's
like well it was a dream
no sorry wasn't a dream was way more
real than any dream in fact it was
actually more real than
life well what do you do with that
what do you do especially when it's all
within every subject or almost every
subject
one out of 30. yeah exactly no one knows
what to do with that
we don't know what to do with that at
all
and yeah and i mean it's
it's beyond comprehension it is deeply
deeply strange you know one of the
images that
i uh i paused on in one of your lectures
online there's an older lecture i
believe was
a side-by-side comparison of two
drawings one
of or i should say a piece of artwork of
the scandinavian
tree of life and the peruvian amazonian
tree of life and uh
if you want if you don't mind taking a
moment just to describe that or i could
try to recall it
uh it was it was really striking and
then you and then you shortly thereafter
had a drawing your son had
put together and the overlap was uh
really hard to wrap your head around in
in some respects
no the drawing my son made yeah i have
it in my office he was about six when he
made it
it's stunning on one side there's a
forest
full of pine trees and then there's a
river running down the middle
then on the other side there's a town
but the town is all mushrooms like
like amanita muscaria mushrooms so all
the houses have mushroom caps
and so there's an order there's order on
one side and chaos on another and the
river runs between them
and then out of the river grows a
beanstalk and the beanstalk
stretches up to heaven the clouds are
there and saint peter's there by the
gates
like it's not like my son had any
particular christian religious education
like he didn't we didn't go to church
and i saw him draw that and i thought
that's
unbelievable i can't believe you drew
that because it's
it's a shamanic drawing it's chaos and
order those are the two subsets of
existence
right at the point they meet out of the
river grows the tree of life
it reaches up to heaven that and the
shaman
and they call they climb the tree of
life and they go to heaven
and you know when merce elia people who
studied the shaman
many of them thought that if the
experience was drug induced that somehow
it had been pathologized that wasn't
part of the
actual tradition but i think that's
completely wrong is that
people have been using psychoactive
drugs to
transcend their consciousness for god
only knows how long
one of the most interesting hypotheses i
ever encountered i think that was
terence mckenna
he thought that psilocybin mushrooms and
human beings co-evolved
so who knows you know um
the stoned ape hypothesis yeah it's
a and what's what's further more
interesting is that we are not the only
species
who seeks altered states of
consciousness
i have a little book about animals who
seek out psychoactive experiences
flies even that's why amanita muscaria
is called uh what is it the fly fly a
garrick
because flies stoned yeah
yeah yeah even flies reindeer
even flies yeah it's very strange it's
very very strange it is it is very
safe to say that we do not know what to
do with that uh
yeah well we don't we also don't what we
also don't know what to do with things
we don't know what to do with
you know that's the problem with opening
pandora's box is that if
you have your life reasonably well
conceptualized
and then you have an experience that
indicates to you that you just don't
know what the hell's going on at all
it's like
well what do you do then yeah and
in fairness this is uh maybe a subset of
what you're describing but
a term i was introduced to by roland was
ontological shock
yeah and fewer though the better
yeah for that reason these are not
compounds to be taken casually well
ontological shock produces
post-traumatic stress disorder there's a
whole literature on antolo
they don't call it ontological shock
it's generally termed
something like disruption of fundamental
axioms it's exactly the same idea
you know and one half of that's terror
and the other half is awe
and that's why trips can go bad
because you can you can get the terror
side of the ontological shock
which is also why the therapeutic
wrapper
that is used by say hopkins or by
maps who is working with the mdma
assisted psychotherapy is so important
because
these compounds can re-traumatize or
traumatized if you
or if used in an irresponsible
context or even if used responsibly
quite frankly that risk exists
well because even the safety precautions
that are put in place
they can certainly decrease the
probability that the trip will be
negative but that doesn't mean they
alleviate the ontological shock they do
it
at the moment so it doesn't go astray
during the trip but
you know there's still the long-term
sequelae to
to consider i need to use that word more
sequelae
that is a great word you mentioned your
son was not
uh these are not the exact words you
used but brought up religious
you've also described knowledge of the
stories in the bible as quote vital to
proper psychological health
and you have a lecture series called the
psychological significance
of the biblical stories so people can
dive in there
but for those who have not studied the
bible
is this a study you recommend to
everyone
and if so why well i don't know if i
would recommend anything to everyone
um biblical
our culture grew out of the bible it's
grounded in the bible for better or
worse
and so if you want to know who you are
and why you think the way
you think like you think you know the
way you think you think you
think you don't or very rarely
like the thoughts thoughts are greater
than you are
in some sense i mean and it's very rare
that you don't think
that you think something that someone
else hasn't thought you know
i can't remember who said it might have
been alfred north whitehead that
you know everyone's the unconscious
proponent of some
philosopher they don't everyone is the
unconscious proponent of some
philosopher
so now
thought exists in a hierarchy value
especially in relationship to value
and the more profound the thought the
more it deals with
fundamental values and the fundamental
value is one upon which many other
values
depend that's that's that's like the
technical definition of a hierarchy i
can give you an example so for example
imagine you're in a committed
relationship
and you're you know you and your wife
have an arrangement to do the dishes and
it's her turn and she doesn't do them
well that's a minor league ontological
shock because
well it has implications possibly for
her honesty you know and perhaps not
maybe she was tired that night god only
knows but
it's a deviation from what's expected
and you know generally those things are
knitted up pretty quickly and whether or
not your wife does the dishes
when she's supposed to once really
doesn't destabilize you that much
because not much else depends on it now
if she did it 10 times or something like
that well then you might start to
question her commitment to your
agreements and then you might question
her honesty and then you might question
your relationship
and you know that you can go down a
rabbit hole pretty quickly
but if your partner has an affair
that tends to be quite a shock because
you've
modeled your plans for behavior and even
for
perception of the world on the
assumption of fidelity
and if that assumption is demolished
then all those plans
dis dissolve and then the uncertainty
comes rushing in and that's
very hard on you psychophysiologically
and so
anyways there's a hierarchy of values
and
the deeper you go the more the values
look religious
almost by definition it's in fact you
could say that that's a definition is
that
the deepest values are religious this is
something i tried to impress upon sam
harris now
you know he didn't like the terminology
religious but it doesn't to me it
doesn't really matter because
you could replace it with okay deep then
you know like have it your way we have a
word for the deepest of values and
that's
religious and so what happens when you
encounter those values well
you you tremble
and you might think well not me it's
like well huh
all that means is that you're protected
to a degree you cannot possibly imagine
and one day maybe not maybe you'll be
lucky and you'll go through life
without being knocked pass over tea
kettle so to speak
but but perhaps not you run into someone
malevolent for example
and then the scales will fall from your
eyes
so anyways the deepest values are
religious and
our religious document is the bible and
the bible is an absolute mystery
so athei i don't care if you're
atheistic or not i mean and this lecture
series was for everyone and lots of
lots of people have watched it weirdly
enough it packed the theaters that i was
lecturing in
of all the bizarre things and you know
it was mostly young men coming to listen
to
some half-baked psychologist talk about
religious matters for an hour and a half
the deepest questions are religious
questions and the bible is the best
answer we have and if you don't like
that well
fine do better good luck i mean there's
wisdom in that book that's
it's unbelievable the story of cain and
abel i have a whole lecture on cain and
abel
that story is one paragraph long and you
can think about that for the rest of
your life you know it's the first two
human beings
fratricidal murder with a genocidal
twist
all packed up into a story one paragraph
long
and it's all resentment it's like cain
kane's sacrifices are rejected by god
okay what does that mean
that's easy you make sacrifices to
improve your future and you do that
on the basis of faith you believe that
if you conduct yourself in a certain way
fate is likely to smile upon you because
why else would you make the sacrifices
and sometimes that doesn't happen you
make the sacrifices and
the reward isn't forthcoming and will
that make you bitter
well in all probability how bitter
how about bitter enough to destroy the
ideal
that's all packed into that story it's
it's i don't understand it
i don't understand how that's possible i
have a hypothesis you know that
a scientific hypothesis is as the story
is transmitted across time
everything that's superfluous gets
stripped away because it's not memorable
and then all that happens
after thousands of years of playing
telephone is that
what's absolutely not forgettable is
retained
but i don't think that's a comprehensive
hypothesis
it's partially true and i think the
story of cain and abel it's like when it
opened itself up to me
it just knocked i've never recovered
from that i don't think
when you think of stories and you use
stories
and you tell stories very effectively
and you talk about say pinocchio
you use biblical stories you're very
engaging
sort of interpreter and transmitter of
stories when you're working on say
beyond order this new book
how do you think of composing your
stories
or your messages so that they are not
lost
so that they have some durability or
transmissibility well i'm always
mostly when i'm writing i'm trying to
figure something out although as i've
written
for as the period of time over which
i've been writing has lengthened
i'm spending more time communicating the
ideas and less time figuring them out
when i wrote my first book which was
maps of meaning
pretty much all i was doing was trying
to figure something out it was
just an exercise in sustained thought
and i worked on it
for from 1985 to 1999 about three hours
a day and i thought about it
especially when i was in my 20s all the
time i was thinking about it like
13 hours a day and the ideas were just
running through my mind at
a rate far higher than i'm capable of
now
i was trying to figure something out i
was trying to figure out i was trying to
understand malevolence
i suppose among other things but when i
wrote
the last two books i i was trying to
communicate some of what i thought i had
learned
and so
but it's still a lot of it's still
trying to solve a
to to answer a question when i lecture
for example
and i usually do that without notes i
have a question in mind it's like okay
well
when in the biblical lectures for
example the first
one is i think it's about two hours long
on the first sentence of genesis
the question is well what does this
sentence mean and so the lecture is an
exploration of what it means
and i'm trying to think it through and
at the same time i'm communicating that
process of thinking it through and
that's what i'm doing with my books and
i the books are written to me you know
which is why i think i've gotten away
with giving advice
the books aren't really advice or if
they are i'm included in the population
of idiots who needs the advice
so you know these are things i haven't
there's the last chapter is be grateful
in spite of your suffering
you know i've had real struggle with
that
so although i know perfectly well that
resentment
regardless of the cause is not
productive
it's certainly understandable
grabbing what you just said and maybe
going to a somewhat
metal level i am going to shoehorn in
victor frankel because i
i don't want to leave that loose end for
for listeners
i frankel talks about the desire to
finish his book as one of the sources of
meaning
that got him through the concentration
camps
uh did did your book and i don't know
the timeline for having worked on it
served a similar purpose over the last
18
to 24 months absolutely absolutely it
was life raft
i was i was devastated when i finished
it
which is common experience you know be
people and it speaks to the nature of
human motivation we often think well
once i get to point
b that's where you're headed everything
will be okay it's like no that's not the
case at all is that now you need a new
point b
so and that was really you know because
i don't work at the university anymore
and i don't have my clinical practice
anymore and
um so that those are losses
to of structure for me and i had the
book to
anchor myself while i was so ill and
um it was invaluable
and still is for that matter
uh i want to ask you about the title
beyond order but before i get to that
i'm just planting the seed
i'd love to ask you this is a question
that a friend of mine several friends of
mine
wanted me to ask some version of and i
would like to hear your answer
and that is how would you recommend
someone
think about meaning or constructing or
finding meaning
if they have reached the pinnacle of
competence or a high level of competence
in a certain area
i have a friend i won't name him because
i don't know if he would want this
public but i i asked him
some version of this and he said well at
some point you have to either find god
or have kids and having kids is easier
so i had kids
well that speaks to what we discussed
earlier it's like there's many domains
in which to obtain competence you can
find a new domain
but kids for sure that's like look
life is quite straightforward in some
ways find a partner
and stick with them you know that's hard
try to make yourself into better people
if you can
it's a challenge have kids have
grandkids thank god i have grandkids
thank god i have kids
you know they they they're they're
they're
that's an they're of unquestionable
virtue
and so then if you're lucky you have
other projects
and and you're healthy enough to to
undertake them
um with regards to how people should
search for meaning well it's
the first thing i do like i said with my
clients as i do a
on a scan of their life
and we have you mentioned it at the
beginning when you introduced me
i have a program a self authoring at
selfauthoring.com that helps people with
this it helps you write an autobiography
sort of figures out who you are it helps
you assess your
personality traits positive and negative
and then it it helps you make a plan for
the future
and people have found that useful so
beyond order what is the genesis of that
title how did you arrive at that title
as far as i can tell in the world of
value
so let's think about value for a minute
if you move towards something you value
it
otherwise you wouldn't move towards it
you
there's an old joke about the chicken is
why did the chicken cross the road
and the answer that is well he thought
the other side was better
well that's that's the case you know and
in order we need a gradient of value to
organize
our action and what you have to
prioritize because you can't do
everything at once and so you do the
thing that's most
important right now now and that means
you're in a world of importance
and that's a value that that's a value
world and the value world
as far as i can tell has two broad
components the taoists talked about it
as yin and yang and
broadly speaking its order and chaos
and order tends to be represented with
masculine symbols and chaos
tends to be represented for feminine
with feminine symbols
that doesn't mean order is male and
chaos is
female and you know i've been pilloried
for this even though it's hardly my
proposition but that
the idea of the patriarchy
is a symbolic it's it's use of
masculine symbolism to represent order
so anyways order
is where what happens order is
you're in order when what you want to
happen happens when you
act and so that's reassuring because not
only do you get what you want but the
fact that you get what you want
indicates that your
theory about how to get what you want is
true
and every time you fail you don't get
what you want but you also
undermine the validity of the theory
that you're using to organize your
perceptions and your actions that's
partly why people don't like to fail
because you don't know how far back that
can
uh echo how far down your hierarchy of
presuppositions that can echo if you're
clinically depressed
every minor failure means you're
worthless human being
and you never know when a failure is
going to demonstrate that you know it
can
in any case there's chaos and order
they're the two great domains and
you have to contend with chaos because
too much of it overwhelms you you drown
in it
it's the flood and that happens when
your life gets beyond you and you're
somewhere where no matter what you do
nothing you want happens it's a domain
of
terror and pain now it's also a domain
of unlimited possibility
because outside of what you know is
everything you don't know
and there's untold riches to be gathered
from the domain of everything you don't
know
but that doesn't mean it it still needs
to be managed it's
dangerous now the domain of order is the
same way it's like
if if order becomes too extreme then
everything
becomes cramped it becomes totalitarian
and then
that starts to pathologize that's the
dying king
the king who's dying for lack of the
water of life is the old tyrant
who can no longer see beyond his own
presuppositions
and so my first book concentrated more
on
pathologies of chaos and
and the second book more on pathologies
of order
and they're they're a match set in in
that regarding so far as i was
successful at doing that
and you know the liberal types they're
very sensitive to pathologies of order
and the conservative types are very
sensitive to pathologies of chaos
but they're both right it's just there's
no final solution to that problem
you're stuck with it it's an existential
uh it's an eternal existential concern
that's why mythological language is
standard across people is no matter who
you are no matter when you live
you always have to deal with the fact
that some things
escape your competence and no matter
where you are no matter
who you are you have to you have to
adapt to the fact of
the existence of a value structure
that's shared across a social
group it's the fundamentals so those are
fundamental constituent elements of
human experience
and we have symbols for them and we all
understand the symbols so for example in
pinocchio
this is i'm not going to go into this
because it's too complicated but
no one balks at a puppet going to the
bottom of the ocean and being swallowed
by a whale
why it makes no sense
there's nothing about that that makes
sense
right it's not it's obviously not an
empirical description
of the objective world but it's so
clearly real that a four-year-old can
follow it it's a mystery
you know the whale breathes fire in
pinocchio
it's a dragon
and why
why is that well we face dragons forever
that's what a human being is it's
it's a creature that faces the dragon
the dragon can burn you to a crisp but
it has
it has what you need that's the world
it'll burn you up but it has what you
need and so then the question is how do
you stop from getting burned up and get
what you need
and the answer to that is that you mold
yourself into the hero
and that's a religious story and you say
well is it true
and the answer to that is it depends on
what you mean by true
and you know that's a weasel answer in
some ways but it's not
it's because it's such a deep question
that it can't be put forth without
discussing the definition of true
so it's as deep a question as what is
true
now you know it could be that
the i would say that part of the
cultural war
is a criticism of the motif of the hero
that's darada's fellow centrism
western culture is fellow go-centric i
would say human culture as fellow
fell logo-centric i think derek it was
wrong about that it's human culture
it's it's man so to speak against nature
although sometimes it's man against
culture and sometimes it's man against
man
it's man against nature and we triumph
as the hero and maybe that story isn't
true or isn't correct but it
that's us and if it isn't correct well
then
we're uh evolutionary abortion
because that's who we are and i would
say well before you throw it aside maybe
you should try it
you don't have a better option anyways
and the law and
there there are
what does it mean to try it mostly i
would say it means
it means two things it means to
practice love and that means
assume that things are valuable and act
according to that assumption and it
requires truth which is
don't say what you know to be untrue
and you know when i tried to unpack the
first sentence of genesis
in the context of the broader biblical
narrative
what appears to be happening is that
there's a proposition that god is guided
by love and uses truth to create
it's something like that and
maybe love is something like the wish
that all being would flourish
there isn't a better story than that
what effect do you hope your new book to
have
i know that's that might seem like a
lazy question but i'm going to keep it
broad i'd just
be interested to hear your thoughts
what would what would be success a
successful effect
for this book looking back 12 months
from now 24 months from now
well i would like it would be lovely if
it had the same effect on people as the
last book appeared to have
you know i'm i mean it's comforting to
me to
read through my youtube comments oddly
enough because that isn't generally a
place people would go for comfort
you know untold numbers of people
have said to me in person but
publicly in in that way that
they've put their lives together at
least in some ways
and
you talked about victor frankl you know
when i wrote maps of meaning i said well
i was interested in malevolence
i was deeply affected by the accounts
i'd read of what happened in the second
world war and
in germany and what happened in soviet
union and in china
these horror shows
that characterize the 20th century
constrain malevolence
and so if you study malevolence you
start to understand what the opposite of
that is
the opposite of malevolence is something
like the hero's journey
you know and it's it's easy to be
cynical about that but
well it's not that easy because if
you're cynical about that then you
undermine your own life
and everyone knows this this is the
other thing that's so interesting
everyone knows this
you never teach someone you love to lie
you're always appalled if you have a son
or daughter
you're always appalled if they don't
tell the truth
you know in the deepest part of your
heart
that if you don't tell the truth
the world falls apart
and that's actually true you know i
talked about unearned wisdom
it's it's no trivial matter
to understand that you know dostoevsky
said
everyone is responsible for everything
that happens to
them and everything that happens to
everyone else as well
and you know that's an insane statement
and he was a very extreme person but
it's also
true and i think that's part of what
people
get a glimpse of when they have a
hallucinogenic induced religious
experience it's like
there's a lot more resting on you than
you think
and you know that you don't wake up in
the morning
berating yourself for telling the truth
you wake up at four in the morning
braiding yourself for violating your
conscience
you know and classically in in at least
in some strains of christian thinking
conscience is associated with christ or
with the holy spirit it's the
it's the voice of god within and
i'm aware of all the criticisms of ideas
like that but you know it's pretty
it's really something that you can't
control
your conscience so what is it exactly
it's not you you're responsible to it
it holds you accountable
it transcends you so what is it
well if you think it's nothing well
violate it for a while and see what
happens
so you know i hope what i wrote in
beyond order is true
you know and if it's true it should do
some good
because what's true does good at least
that's the hope
jordan i think we're
running up on time i want to be
respectful of your schedule
i have sincerely enjoyed
this conversation i'm glad you exist i'm
glad you write
i'm very excited for
you and your readers with respect to
beyond order
12 more rules for life and i encourage
people to check it out is there anything
that you would like to add in terms of
closing remarks or a question
to my audience a request of my audience
anything that you would like to say no
i've been thinking about you know i my
book is coming out on march 2nd and i've
been thinking about
what to do about that and i think the
most appropriate thing to do
is to thank people the people who've
watched my lectures and listened to them
and
who have bought tickets to my lectures
and who've
bought and read my book my family
has received an unbelievable outpouring
of support
it's saved my life
so
appreciate it thank you so much jordan
and thank you to you too i appreciate
the conversation
you